[Musique]
ok mais l'action c'est dangereux à nous
y voilà pour simplifier on va dire qu'un
vaccin fait un médicament comprend pas
pour soigner une maladie mais pour
éviter de l'attraper et de la refiler à
tout le monde
tous les médicaments ont des effets
secondaires potentiels leur est fréquent
ou rares bénin ou graves
globalement les bénin ça peut arriver
mais on parle de trucs genre l'endroit
où on a fait la piqûre qui grattent qui
fait un peu mal un peu de fièvre etc
mais les effets indésirables graves ils
sont super rare
c'est même la condition à laquelle on
autorise la vente d'un médicament ou
d'un vaccin qui fasse plus de bien que
de mal
ça s'appelle la balance bénéfices
risques et c'est réévaluée régulièrement
si vous devez retenir une seule chose
retenait sa le risque de choper une
maladie grave si on n'est pas vaccinée
il est beaucoup plus élevé que le risque
d'avoir un effet indésirable grave lié à
un maintien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]